hey what's up i'm bella thorne and i'm
doing the wired auto complete interview
it's pretty exciting waste your time and
stick around
is bella thorne hair real well not
currently
it's a wig i'm wearing a wig right now
when i'm not wearing a wig
i'm wearing a top knot and that's my
shitty quality hair that's just
done up in a top not every day right now
it's a really swampy
like green color anyway it's really not
cute is bella thorne
justin bieber's backup dancer is this a
joke
can i just like just be i don't know
what that one is
is bella thorne jurassic world
am i looking at this right oh maybe they
think i'm in jurassic world the
redheaded girl
bryce dallas howard maybe they think i'm
her or maybe they just think i'm a
dinosaur
right what is bella thorne up to
bro don't even get me started
what am i not up to my goodness i'm not
up to skating
still haven't learned how to skate i'm
not up to driving yet
oh i'm not up to zucchini what is
bellathorn
zodiac side a libra
i like libras i'm pretty proud of my
zodiac sign i'd be pretty upset if i was
like a scorpio sorry
for anybody in the room who is a scorpio
whenever i meet a scorpio i'm like hey
hey
gotta be careful what bella thorne
phone number oh
what bella thorne's dog's name
oh tampon and chuco in grumps and then
we have uh 19 cats
yeah we love animals what
bella foreign favorite color it's
anywhere in between
purple and red does bella thorne have
tattoos
oh yes i have so many of them i have a
little i'll have a little heart right
here and i think it's pretty cute always
i got a matching heart on my wrist and
be squared
and then youngest i got this matching
with my girlfriend tana i don't know i
got some finger tattoos
i don't know what do you want from me i
have a tattoo again okay
does bella thorne have siblings yes
i do i have my twin sister dani
who's the besties and i have my brother
remy
and then my other sister kylie as well
and those are my siblings yes it is uh
siblings of four is bellathorn
vegan oh that's like the top one
i'm not i'm so sorry guys i really want
to be though
my sister's a vegan so we eat a lot of
vegan food but
man bacon oh gets me every time
is bella thorne married oh you guys
snuck that one in there did you
that is for my own personal knowledge
and none for you
is bella thorne alive i don't know how
dead do my eyes look today
dead right isabella thorne spanish
i am z cuban i know
cameron diaz is cuban too okay can you
just get off my dick about it guys can
you just
is bellathorn left-handed uh no
okay okay ooh what bella thorne
hair color well like right now i said
it's like swampy green
i had a green for the last movie i did
but my hair color
naturally is blonde what college do both
one go to
none
no yeah i actually have like no
schooling education whatsoever
schooling was just never a big thing in
our family i learned how to read from
acting with my dyslexia so i didn't
really
learn that in school and then i really
wanted to go to usc to study film
but all the directors that i've worked
with told me that that's not really
a necessary idea you can't do anything
you want to even if you don't go to
school for it
what does bellathorn look like
what i don't know that is fugly no
kidding um
i don't know what do i look like
what are these profiles giving you huh
hmm
what does this look like to you huh how
did bella thorne grow taller i got knee
injections
that's a joke it was me being sarcastic
i think people thought i was really
short on shake it up because zendaya's
really tall
so for a while i used to get in person
like wow
you are so tall in real life and i'm
only five eight
actually like i guess it's pretty tall i
don't know
where bella thorne
from oh miami where bellathorn lives
you you broke into my house
twice don't you know that already
where bella thorne now right here
in this interview with uh like six
movies coming out this year and
uh owning a record label and she's super
busy
where bella thorne
what
i don't know what they were asking what
they wanted to know
i don't know what i think of of these
questions
you know i almost like where's like does
bellathorne do tongue tricks like yes
i do what do they want from me
why are they looking these things up
where am i
about from